for the second time in a month the u.s.
is sending troops to Saudi Arabia to
help protect that country from Iranian
attacks in response to continued threats
in the region I've ordered the
deployment to the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia of two additional fighter
squadrons and supporting personnel along
with additional Patriot and fat air and
missile defense batteries taken together
with other deployments I've extended or
authorized within last month this
involves about 3,000 the United States
forces a few hundred US troops went to
Saudi Arabia in mid-september after
Iranian drones and cruise missiles
destroyed part of the up cake and kohai
soil facilities Washington also imposed
sanctions on Iran's central bank and its
sovereign wealth fund and this is on top
of our oil sanctions and our financial
institutions sanctions but this latest
deployment is much larger because the
Trump administration says the threat
from Tehran has worsened we are
accumulating risk of a regional war I've
been saying that for over a year
here in another fora and then on
September 14th we had an act of war and
we continued to accumulate risk of a
worse conflict a Mideast policy expert
said the troop deployment is important
but not as important as many assume the
additional missile defense systems seem
to be a clear reaction to the successful
attack by drones and by missiles on the
Saudi oil facilities which actually was
a great embarrassment to both the United
States and to Saudi Arabia
u.s. officials insist they're not being
provocative by sending more troops and
weapons to Saudi Arabia chances are
officials in Tehran will disagree
Rozlyn jordan al jazeera Washington